is it safe to come out yet is nuclear
war over I'll take my chances fallout
guys follow beloved franchise from
Bethesda and along with it finally here
we can finally breathe I'm Whitney more
and I'm here to catch you up on
everything fallout 4 this is hashtag
news it says dead the studio behind the
Fallout series put a mysterious
countdown clock on their website that
led to this
let's go pal fallout 4 is real it's
gonna be in our lives soon what does
this mean for Fallout more awesome story
cool weapons over price deal see you
probably but I'm gonna buy it well this
there's a loan is so exciting I'll know
way more about it after but that is his
III conference on jun 14th my heart
balls are tingling we've been blue
balled enough now my heart balls are
super happy about it what fallout such a
big series we got to check out where we
are in the story so far who are the
series even starts in twenty seven seven
the whole United States is wiped from
nuclear war someone driving away isn't
neglectful dad during the apocalypse the
fallout 1 was released in 1997 and it
takes place in a post-apocalyptic
Southern California main task for the
vault dweller is to go retrieve this
lost water chip to make the water clean
again and also on top of that he is to
stop this group of mutants that's led by
this horrible entity that calls himself
the master do you join the unity or do
you die sounds cool right fella she was
released in 1998 this time they're still
famine you got to save all these
villagers and also it introduces the
Enclave which is the remnants of the
United States government and they're
super bad guy is super super bad
post-apocalyptic USA don't trust it
don't trust that Gulman now there were
two games released between fall at two
and three but they suck so we're not
going to talk about him so then fallout
3 came out and it's amazing it totally
changed the game because it's open world
you can be whatever you want you can
wander and explore you're basically a
vault dweller that leaves for the first
time anybody has left and it's been 200
years since people went under the bunker
and your goal is to find your father
because he's got the secret to clean
water but your dad is rainy ssin Megaton
destroyed you didn't have anything to do
with that did you it takes place 200
years after the 1950s everything's Howdy
Doody
and do off and real cool music there's
leather or gang called the tunnel snakes
that are awesome and there's crazy
mutants that you have to fight and you
get to choose if you want to be good and
evil like you could blow up megaton
that's your first challenge and you can
decide if you want to be a dick or if
you want to save some people so then we
got new vegas which people had a lot of
complaints about i am a die-hard fan so
I still loved it still had awesome 50s
culture in it really hilarious oh I'm
Utahns head is just like which brings us
to fall out for now the most recent
rumor is that Guillermo del Toro's
production company in arada pictures
worked on the cinematic trailer we know
this because a CG artist leaked it on
his linkedin profile thanks dude we
appreciate you you and a real MVP now
what do we know about follow up for
fallout 4 takes place in boston which
makes a lot of sense because there's a
side quest and fallout 3 with a
scientist that references a place called
the Institute the Institute is going to
something like a post-apocalyptic MIT
also eric Todd Dellums who played three
dog and fallout 3 you say one of the key
phrases and your reward is hearing my
golden boy tweeted that you might be
reprising his role sometime soon I see
what you're doing and I want to be a
part of it Todd let me call in to your
radio program to me I'm lone wanderer
I'm it if Skyrim is any indication we're
gonna have a super cool leveling system
I liked fallouts but Skyrim was way more
advanced it would be so cool to live the
to smash them together legalize video
gay marriage I'm gonna marry to video
games and have no friends I really hope
that there's an online co-op I mean when
I play fallout I don't talk to anybody I
just shut myself in my living room and
play for 16 hours straight but it'd be
so cool if I can do that with friends
that would just so do wonders to my
social life not seeing people but
talking to them on a on a headset
subscribe to new many rock stars if you
want more videos like this and more
Whitney's like me what did you learn I
hope you learned a little bit about
thermonuclear
your warfare that's a hard word to say
that's a two dollar work thermo nuclear
what do you think about my wat for
comment below let me know tummy or are
you good or bad in the game what's your
favorite costume what's your alignment
I'm Whitney more and I need to go find
Liam Neeson cuz he's my dad please send
me more quests how about a question we
play baseball together or where you show
up to my dance recital we'll talk more
about this when there's time how about
one of those quests